[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Приазов'я, Стрілкове
Садиба сільського туризму «Аґрус Азов»]
У цих краях у мене, взагалі,
ніякого коріння не було і немає.
Ні знайомих, ні однокласників,
ні родини — нікого.
Тож, в принципі, дуже благополучно, те, що в мене
тут односельчани такі є.
До того, як знайшла собі тут будинок,
я була тут лише один раз.
До того ж, мені вперше не сподобалось.
Тобто я якось не знайшла
комфортного місця для себе ніяк.
[Оксана Чорнобривцева
Засновниця садиби]
І тому повернулася сюди
уже багато років потому.
Щодо першого сприйняття —
це, взагалі, закономірна річ.
Це як інородне тіло, воно з'являється
і виникає якась реакція.
Але не обов'язково негативна.
Просто, буває якась пересторога, може,
типу, ким та якою виявиться ця людина,
чи буде це добрий сусід,
чи це буде якась морока,
з якою матиму проблеми
і яка порушуватиме спокій.
Мені дуже подобається,
що можна звернутися чи по допомогу,
чи просто дружньо привітатися
з будь-ким із сусідів.
Багато з них в чомусь мені допомагали, звичайно.
Я коли вперше зайшла сюди, у двір,
ще нічого не знаючи і не бачачи,
але я одразу відчула, що сюди повернуся.
Думаю, це має бути місцем саме для мене.
Це типовий такий для цієї місцевості будинок.
Радгоспи коли тут організовувались,
було багато переселенців.
У нас якось так...
От у мене питають... Працівники.
Я навіть не можу цього слова застосувати,
тому що у мене всі — помічники.
Серйозно.
У нас родина або ближча родина, дальня родина —
у нас так всі отут задіяні.
Ми намагалися максимально використовувати натуральні матеріали.
Будинок наш оригінальний,
він побудований з ракушняка.
Ракушняк добули тут, на Арабатській стрілці.
Ще люди самі нарізали його колись, пилками.
А нові будівлі у нас з кримського ракушняка.
Ще от трошки буквально, коли було можна...
Ну тобто ще нічого такого там
[в Криму] не відбулося...
Ми привезли кримської ракушки
сюди і будували з неї.
Дерево — дах у нас натуральний
з Івано-Франківської області.
Кожна плашечка — це ручна робота.
Дахи нашого подвір'я з ґонти
[балочне перекриття] зроблені.
Зі смерекової.
Тобто це навіть не ріжеться —
колеться вздовж волокон.
Такий дах має стояти довго,
надійно і приємно.
Ну от, будівельні матеріали,
щось симпатичніше чи оригінальніше —
це дуже незручно, все треба завозити.
Або немає вибору взагалі або низька якість.
Ми з нашою родиною намагаємося
по можливості, звичайно, подорожувати.
Дуже багато я подорожую на авто.
І коли вдається побувати в Європі,
ми любимо зупинятися в таких садибах.
Вони своїм існуванням, станом,
успіхом, своїми історіями тільки
підтверджують, що це і як бізнес успішно
і є необхідним для підтримки
певного рівня життя.
Вони досить успішні. Це перший доказ. Все.
Я не пам'ятаю статистики, але,
на жаль, це має свої наслідки,
що у нас, якщо не помиляюсь,
більше ніж 70% населення
взагалі не буває за межами своєї області,
я вже не кажу про країну.
Тобто, ну а що ми можемо бачити.
Скажімо так: наслідки радянського союзу
ще досить відчутні.
Коли ми робили емблему на паркані,
«Садиба сільського туризму»,
деякі місцеві дивились нас навіть зі співчуттям, мовляв «Ну що ж ви такі?»
Якби було написано:
«Люкс-номери для VIP-гостей»...
Сільський туризм — кому воно потрібно...
Тобто це не круто.
От таке місце все ще вважається не круто.
Круто — це пластиковий рай.
Ось те, що треба.
До нас приїжджали просто познайомитися
спостерігачі ОБСЄ,
просто дізнатися, чим займаються люди,
як все тут відбувається, чи добре все,
бо я так розумію, в них є свої обов'язки.
Вони відвідують наших військових,
вони спілкуються з керівництвом району.
Я дуже переживаю, дуже вболіваю за Україну.
Те, що відбувається в наші часи,
але неможливо досі у це повірити, насправді,
що це взагалі може відбутися у наш час.
Я займалася будинком,
розпочиналася тут реконструкція, ремонт,
і паралельно завозили військову техніку.
І новини такі, дуже гнітючі,
і багато людей, які тебе запитують:
«Чи не маєте ви втікати,
а не засновувати тут щось?».
Мене це не лякало. Не знаю, чому.
Я в таких справах, дуже важливих,
покладаюся лише на відчуття.
Дорослі люди негативно ставились до цього,
відверто негативно,
навіть активно негативно.
А діти раділи, тому що ми захищені,
все добре, все буде прекрасно.
Українських солдат вони сприймали
дуже позитивно й раділи цьому.
Я намагалася бачити тільки це.
І отут якраз настав час,
коли все так чітко розділилося на чорне і біле.
Це просто блок-пост.
Тобто вони і ми.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Дмитро Охріменко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтаж
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
Blooms Corda, ZenBerrym Fudo Kazuki, Tik Tu]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]